hey everybody welcome uh welcome once
again to vacation stream
um have had a beautiful beautiful break
um was on the beach today reading
took place posted a picture to my
instagram of what it looks like to read
most people know what it looks like but
just in case you didn't know you could
see that
uh on my instagram we are standing by
for donald trump uh presumably at the
top of the hour
and i believe he actually does have sort
of a tight schedule today because he's
speaking somewhere he has to leave the
white house so he he may actually be
close to on time today
um i have clips to go through i have all
sorts of different things i do have some
memes to go over with you
i am using um
in the world of uh of of camera lighting
you've got the velvet glove which is
tweaking the lighting churning the
lighting so that it's
the right lighting and then you have
using camera gain
and i'm doing the cheap thing during
this vacation
using camera again and so as the sun
sets
you may see me reach over here oh that's
the wrong way
oh actually no as the sun sets i will
add gain as you can see i've got all
these
look at this oh my goodness look at me
right here isn't that beautiful
but in any case i'm using the cheap
method
um the the the hammer of lighting rather
than the
uh the velvet glove so we're gonna be
doing that
uh it's great to see everybody i see
people are sending me messages
on twitch people want to see some town
hall stuff which i am
absolutely going to show you i've got
those things pulled up
uh coming in addison adsit
metz says i was bernie or bus but you
helped me come around on supporting
biden glad to hear that
um let's see what else we've got here
other messages
okay let me get away from super chats
briefly because i do have a bunch of
stuff to show you guys
i don't know if you saw this but oh wait
no i have this on mine
here it is so here's cnbc host jim
cramer
calling nancy pelosi crazy nancy take a
look at this
i mean what deal can we have a crazy
nancy i'm sorry
that was the president i i have such
reverence for the office
i would cr i mean just giga cringe
oh god we'd never use that term
but it is but you just didn't but you
just did
you come on you know come on
come on and then here was the apology
today
which is almost as crazy today when i
talked to house speaker nancy pelosi
once
walked on the street scored a very
stupid comment how many
syllables are in that it was a
tongue-in-cheek attempt to make a point
about the
harsh tone of the negotiations in
washington but i felt completely flat
and i apologize for that
as i said immediately after the comment
i want to make it clear
that i have an incredible amount of
respect for both the speaker and of
course the office she
holds oil okay i mean it's like he
it i it's so not believable i would have
i would respect him more instead of
doing such a stupid apology
to just go down with the ship if you
know what i mean
i would have preferred to see that
because this is just so obviously
not genuine and idiotic and something he
was forced to do
it's it's just it's insane uh the vegan
villainess
says via super chat what do you think
about trump's health aide michael
caputo's insane rant on social media
about left-wing hit squads
i uh hope you're enjoying your vacation
yeah i actually haven't seen it
um i've been paying attention to very
very little
so i haven't seen it uh vegan villain s
but i will check it out in time for when
we are back
next week also big thank you to drugs
not
thugs for 20 for subscribing with twitch
prime over on uh twitch today
thank you very very much um okay
other clips let's look at oh before we
go on to clips
i don't know if you guys did you guys
see my celebration after i got 1 million
youtube subscribers i don't know if you
guys saw this check this out
i don't know how many you guys went to
that um it was by invitation only but i
did invite
um any number of you and uh yeah that
was that was a real big party so we got
that
and then here's a pic i don't know how
many of you saw my vacation picture i'm
at weekend with bernie
and as you can see producer pat is here
i'm here wearing my
prepper headlamp so i've got everything
i need here and we are with bernie no
this is a fake vacation picture but i
did post let me see how many it is
um
one two two uh
vacation pictures over on my uh on my
instagram
so that is going on and of course we're
all just joking around here and we're
just waiting for donald trump at the top
of the hour
okay let's look at a couple of the clips
from the trump town hall we also have
biden stuff that we can look at
but let me first look at the trump town
hall um
let's see here i mean i don't even know
where to start i want us
i think i want to start with trump
actually no i have the clip i want to
start with trump blaming biden
where is that ah here it is trump tries
to blame
joe biden for not implementing a
national mass mandate despite the fact
that trump is president look at this
proven to lessen the spread of covid
um why don't you support a mandate for
national mass wearing
and why don't you wear a mask more often
well i do wear them when i have to and
when i'm in hospitals and other
locations but
i will say this they
said at the democrat convention they're
going to do a national mandate
that's if biden wins
if they are in power never did it
because they've checked out and they
didn't do it
and a quick a good question is you ask
like joe biden they said we're going to
do a
national mandate unrest called on all
governors to have them it is a statement
but he didn't do it i mean he never he's
not the president
this i did check out my uh youtube clip
from a couple of weeks ago called
trump is running as if he's not
president
and i don't know if it's going to work i
saw some tweets from some people i
respect earlier today saying
it's not going to work i think that
there's enough stupid people in this
country that it could work
sadly now there is
a lot of people don't want to wear masks
there are a lot of people think the
masks are not good
and there are a lot of people what does
that even mean that a mask is not good
well that as an example you have those
people i'll tell you who those people
are
waiters they come over and they serve
you and they have a mask and i saw it
the other day where they were serving me
and they're playing with a mask i'm not
blaming that i'm just saying what
happens
they're playing with a mask so the mask
is over and they're
touching it and put and then they're
touching the plate that can't be good
there are a lot of people if you look at
dr fauci's original statement you look
at a lot of people cdc
you look at a lot of people anyway i
think you guys get the picture it's it's
completely and totally idiotic um let's
see here's let's just
present president obama we're president
of hillary clinton never got in
that would be a what we would have a war
probably a nuclear war with north korea
we we obviously would not we obviously
would not uh barack obama
hillary clinton nuclear weapons against
north korea what what is he talking
about
what is he talking about um let's see
uh what else do we have here oh uh
here's one about the healthcare platform
this is a good one three weeks you
promised an executive order
existing i have it all right but it's
you've been trying to strike down their
existing conditions i have it already
and it's a much better plan for you
and it's a much better plan you say
obamacare i got rid of the individual
mandate which is the worst part of
obamacare
it's sort of like the part that makes it
work the whole law
wouldn't be pertained to you but it
pertained to a lot of people where they
were going
literally bust because they didn't want
to have health insurance
people were going bust paying for it
anyway it was no good
obamacare was a disaster obamacare is
too expensive the premiums are too high
it's a total now what's of course
hilarious is that all of these problems
get worse if you get rid of the mandate
the mandate is needed to subsidize all
of those things it all gets
the problems he's identifying get worse
disaster you're going to have new health
care
and the pre-existing condition aspect of
it will always be in my plan and i've
said that loud and clear that you
haven't come up with it and
we got rid of the individual mandate
which essentially ended obama remember
he already mentioned that i'm a care and
i had a decision only because you're
arguing george
i had a decision to make do i run we
gutted out the worst parts of obamacare
now i have to
make this decision this is he didn't
understand he didn't gut obamacare
he's just trying to make it financially
insolvent he's gotten rid of nothing
in obamacare other than the mechanism
that makes it financially viable it's
it's beyond delusional
three years ago do we run obamacare well
and do a good job and do the best even
though it's never going to be very good
why or do we let it run badly probably
letting it run badly would have been
a better political decision but i
couldn't do that but this is just
complete idiocy and then here donald
trump tries to explain
why he only sees himself as president of
red states
and it it goes very poorly but they know
exactly where i stand
what they want is a bailout of
democrat-run states that are doing
poorly
and you know i don't think this is the
right way to keep talking about
democrats
states the democracies they're american
states america democrat run states are
the ones that are doing badly george if
you look at
new york if you look at illinois now of
course you guys i know you guys know
this
but in case there's any trolls in the
chat um
the places that didn't do well early
didn't do well because they were hit
early before we we even knew what was
going on
understand and um of course
over time what we figured out is that
the policies are actually once once the
virus
was widespread in the entire country it
wasn't about
which states have direct flights to
places that were
early hot spots of of infection
dissemination
policy matters and things have very much
reversed as you all know of course
if you look at a lot of different places
they're doing poorly and cities
in particular cities maybe these cities
are being run so poor
but largely because of the crime they
don't want to do anything about crime
sanctuary cities they have sanctuary
cities where they're protecting
criminals they have things that
the republicans don't have okay and then
lastly
here is a kafka-esque moment i don't
know of any i'm re-watching breaking bad
is one of the things i'm doing on
vacation
here is a kafka-esque moment i won't
even introduce it
i'm just going to play it for you
quality which i agree with you is a
problem i always agreed with that
but if you look under president obama
and biden
the income inequality was phenomenal it
was it was record-setting it was
it was it's getting worse now well we're
talking about a play coming in before
the plague
we were doing very well now we will soon
be doing well again because we're gonna
have a fantastic third quarter equality
which i agree with you
it's uh it's it's truly beyond
explanation it's beyond comprehension
it's it's like nothing that we have seen
uh really ever
really it really ever it's just it's
just incredible
thank you to uh trifton
the strawberry rodeo j phil
and gabby cast for subscribing over on
twitch
um i do have a bunch of super chats to
get to here but before we do that i want
to say a big thank you to randy burton
randy is new member number one today
at joinpackman.com and you can see even
when i travel i
bring this blue bar with me never you
never want to leave home without the
blue bar
above your head and even when i'm at
restaurants that thing is above my head
one out of 25
and we will uh keep an eye on that and
as people sign up
that it that is going to grow is my
prediction let's see some other super
chats coming in
danny thompson asks how many straw man
statements will the straw-haired man
state today
many many uh norwegian
trad archer says could this election in
a worst case end up in a civilian war in
the united states
uh i don't believe that that's going to
happen i don't believe that that's going
to happen
at first arola says at first i wondered
if biden did a debate
if that would be awful today i have
realized trump couldn't convince a
toddler to eat ice cream
no you're bringing up something really
important which is
before the bernie biden debate
you had a bunch of people who were like
insane that biden wasn't going to be
able to put together a sentence
that it was just going to be terrible
for biden and of course it didn't happen
it was fine for biden and biden went on
to win the the primary very easily
there are people with the exact same
expectation for the trump biden debates
that biden's going to be incoherent
he'll be unable to put together a
sentence all of this stuff
it's just not going to happen it's not
going to be like that at all now it's
certainly
possible it's certainly possible that
either candidate does
poorly uh in terms of the in terms of
material in terms of subject matter
that's certainly possible
um but the idea that you know biden's
gonna be unable to put together a
sentence if you're waiting for that i
would my breath you're going to be very
very uh very very very disappointed
uh indeed um okay other
super chats that are coming in oh uh
am i stuck at a million stuck at a
million subscribers come on guys so here
here's what happens on youtube
when you get to a million subscribers
the public numbers
only start updating every 10 000
instead of every thousand so whereas
before they would update like when we
went from 996 to 997.
now we will not see an update until we
get to 1 million
10 000 subscribers okay and right now
we're at one
1 million six thousand so
it's everybody relax everybody relax
it's still we're still up fifteen
hundred to two thousand subscribers a
day
um but we're just it's a different it's
a different game
to get to a million it's a different
game but now what we really want to do
is get to 50 000 followers on twitch
we're just shy of that
and we're gonna work very very hard uh
to get to that
speaking of which thanks to dinosaur cal
for subscribing for 14 months
on twitch which i very much appreciate
other super chats continue to come in
dominic richardson says remember that
cringe 2016
trumpus talking point about how he would
be fine because his children are so good
wonder what happened to that yeah i
don't even remember that
i don't remember that uh lisa says
thanks for hanging with us during your
vacation we miss you how sad are we
enjoy the rest of the week yeah it's
been great so for people who have been
emailing me saying david
there's there's no podcast today
there's an error there's a problem on
your
no podcast uh we're just on vacation
and i said i would pop in and do two or
three streams during some down time
had a great day at the beach today
i've been reading i've been doing all
sorts of things
and uh we've got a little time before
folks reconvene
for dinner in a couple of hours so we
are going to uh
we're just streaming that's what we're
doing i do want to say thank you to
joshua burnett joshua burnett is new
member number two today
at joinpakman.com for people saying that
my stream
is having a problem uh i i'm doing the
best i can with the internet connection
i have
and for people saying turn down the
resolution on twitch i
have no ability to do that i am merely
an affiliate
and uh twitch determines what various
resolutions
my stream uh is available out i've i
have no control over that whatsoever i
very much apologize for that
uh okay let's see what other super chats
are coming in
zachary says david your internet cut out
earlier what did you have to say about
my earlier super chat about vaccines
yeah dr redfield's comment about masks
versus vaccines it's not masks versus
vaccines it's one
serves one purpose which is to prevent
spread when we don't have a vaccine
the vaccine of course is meant to start
getting us back to
normal and that they are two completely
different things and the idea of saying
one is more important or less important
than the other
uh not that's not uh that's not the
analysis i would make my friends
not the analysis i would make sean h
says rewatching breaking bad
the greatest of all time of television
you have impeccable tastes sir do you
have a favorite episode
i don't have a favorite breaking bad
episode but i think my favorite seasons
are the ones that involve
uh all of the um uh
well i i guess i would say seasons three
and four
might be my favorite um
the gustavo fring seasons in general i
think are probably the best
you know i i have to admit the very end
of breaking bad was good
but there was a moment there with the
todd stuff and
todd's uncle where it started to see
seem a little bit forced to me like
those were not
they seemed a little bit like crow
barton storylines
so um yeah that that i think was maybe
my uh
my less uh less less compelling
that was the least compelling moment of
that uh okay let's see so i'm being told
that trump may have delayed this let's
take a look at that
we do have trump's official calendar
ready to go at any time
uh i'm not seeing a delay yet but let's
see if trump tweeted about it
sometimes trump tweets about the delays
545 okay yeah so there is a little bit
of a delay that's okay
uh i do wonder if maybe
i would be able to get is anybody know
if destiny is streaming because i would
be open to the idea of talking to
destiny right now
and see if we can hash out some of those
we've been having
uh let me get logged in and see what's
going on
um i know that there's been a lot of
urgency so to speak
for me to speak to stephen kenneth
and i am glad to try to do that
um he's streaming right now okay all
right let's see if i can get logged in
here
all right just getting on discord here
telling discord that i'm not a robot oh
now i've got to click on
all of the images with crosswalks can
you imagine
all right um
so that was not the right password let's
see here
could be a little difficult to get in
here
okay new login location wow everything's
going i think i should be able to do it
verify my login very good
okay good all right we are in almost
all right
and let's see yeah i think people will
be interested in this
uh let's see if he's around hey you want
to
catch up real quick
all right let's see if we can get
stephen going here
i think it would be interesting just to
get it uh
to get everything set up uh and if
you're standing by we are waiting for a
trump press briefing in about
45 minutes 45 minutes um
let's see here all right steven says
he's good let's see let's start a voice
call here um
microphone to share steven
hey whoa hold on a second
let's see if we can get this uh
so output devices default input is
microphone array
can you hear me stephen yeah i can hear
me
hey how are you pretty good how you
doing
dude uh i i i have to tell you people
have been going crazy
wanting us to talk because there's
people who are
worried about you there's people who are
worried about me because i know you
like do you are you able to catch up
yeah i'm always i'd stream 10 hours a
day i catch up whenever but oh all right
so listen i mean first and foremost the
the catalyst
for everything that i think has gone
down were your comments related to
the thing in kenosha now i want to be
careful about let's not say anything
that could get anybody in trouble
because i it seems like this was the
source of some of the problems but
is that the catalyst that people are
referring to and that people are worried
about you regarding
i don't know who's worried about me but
yeah that was definitely the
inciting incident for sure and is
have you been de-partnered by twitch is
that accurate
yep gonna start doing streaming on
youtube now and what does it mean
exactly to be de-partnered
um you lose all the features that
partners and affiliates have on the site
and you can no longer have subscribers
or run commercials
okay all right i don't know much about
that because i'm not um
i'm not uh a partner and but you so you
are not banned from twitch you're on
twitch right now
yeah for now not bad hopefully that
maintains it but but i mean as we speak
you're you're streaming on twitch
okay and are you doing okay in
like as a as a person or is there
anything there that we should be worried
about
i mean i think i'm doing okay yeah okay
so you're not like
people are acting like you're despondent
or that you're cutting people out there
was something about
uh a guy named vaush that i guess you
have had some kind of falling out oh i'm
trying to like avoid talking to
like i complain about this last time i
don't know how i keep getting sucked
back into this but i'm trying to avoid
talking to like
p socialist and communist online um it's
bad for my business it's bad for my
mental health and it's a waste of time
but i keep getting like sucked back in
by like terminally online people so
that's what i'm trying to avoid
and is that related to the partnering in
some way
um a little bit i think that those
communities were largely involved in
like spam reporting my [ __ ] and
everything yeah oh
okay okay and so i mean listen i don't i
want to be
again i want to be careful it sounds
like from from what i've heard
you and i may have a difference of
opinion on what happened in kenosha but
i think that
you know one of the things i'm having a
problem with is there seem to be a lot
of people demanding
that denouncings take place like that i
denounce you
or that you denounce the left or
whatever and i think i i think that's
not
great
um yeah maybe sure
all right um and and so from in
in terms of what happened in kenosha i
mean are you you're not
are you a gun guy or what what is going
on
um i'm a huge self-defense guy okay
meaning what
oh boy i think i lost you there briefly
oh boy
oh no you're bad you're back yeah you're
pristine now
yeah okay um yeah if you want to defend
your property or your home or your
livelihood
uh or your life with firearms um i think
in the united states you have every
right to do so yeah 100
what you recognize the second amendment
exists
um yeah kind of i mean i don't really
think it's like it's not so much like a
second amendment thing to me
this is more like a moral question i
mean i guess the second amendment does
exist but i don't really care much about
it
i don't know if it influences my
behavior or my thinking of this one way
or another
and then when it came to i mean again
we're going to be real careful here but
when it came to the kenosha situation
did you find it problematic at all or
let's speak hypothetically in order to
maybe keep it cleaner
if someone crosses state lines
is given a gun they're not old enough to
legally have
and then gets involved in a
confrontation in which
in a brief moment one could argue they
were in danger
are they in any way responsible for
their own actions
um you're responsible for the action of
hypothetically of crossing a state line
and getting a firearm illegally sure but
you're not responsible for like
uh or in terms of like you could still
have a justified uh case with
self-defense of course
so like for example so let's say for
instance let's say for example let's say
that uh
let's say that a woman sneaks into a bar
under age let's say she's 18 she's
supposed to be 21 she has a fake id and
she likes to get in
i don't think that once she can if a man
would have tried
sorry you don't think i met you you you
cut out that you don't think a man if a
man tried what
anyway yeah am i cutting out you did but
i'm guessing you were saying it would be
reasonable for a man to assume that that
woman is 21 right
no wait can you hear me yes okay
can you hear me loud and clear oh yeah
okay
if a person were to go into a bar they
weren't allowed to go into
yep and once they were in that bar
somebody tries to assault that person
and then they were to defend themselves
from that assault say with a gun i don't
think i would say well listen
you were 18 you shouldn't have even been
in there so that self-defense was
unjustified
these are two separate things you can be
wrong in that you shouldn't have been in
that place at all you should have gone
to the bar
but it doesn't mean that the
self-defense was unjustified these are
two separate like disparate
issues or whatever so do you remember
that entire george zimmerman trayvon
martin thing
you remember that one in florida george
zimmerman trayvon martin
oh man stephen you know what i don't
know if our connection's holding up i
don't know if it's good enough to do
this in real time
oh can you can you hear me um yeah so i
do you remember the trayvon martin
george zimmerman thing that happened in
florida a few years ago
yep so when
one of the the key things there was that
the entire thing was focused on
did george zimmerman really fear for his
life
and of course that all came after george
zimmerman multiple times decided to
create a confrontation with trayvon
martin
was that pretext relevant is in your
mind
oh man
oh boy this is bad not trick
man zimmerman oh god i don't know if you
can hear me yeah i got you i got your
back okay
zimmerman aggressively pursued trayvon
over and over and over again past
trayvon threatening any particular thing
my understanding is that confrontation
like ultimately ended up with trayvon
dead in the street wasn't it yes
yeah if trayvon would have been like
breaking into zimmerman's house or
something then i would view that case to
be more analogous
but my understanding is that zimmerman
was literally chasing trayvon through
like
the neighborhood and like eventually
they had a confrontation on the street
where um where trayvon
could have had like uh like a legitimate
use of self-defense if he thought
zimmerman was attacking him and then
zimmerman
ended up killing him or murdering him i
guess he said it
isn't crossing state lines and illegally
taking up guns
at least somewhat equivalent to what
george zimmerman did there
do you think that if somebody illegally
crosses state lines and has a gun with
them that if somebody tries to kill them
they have to die
no but that's not it that's not even
what happened he didn't even bring the
guys exactly in other words he crossed
state lines
and then was given a gun why wasn't him
crossing
giving a gun that has nothing to do with
whether or not it was a
legitimate use of self-defense on a
moral level just because you're in a
place you're not supposed to be doesn't
mean you give up all rights to defend
yourself
you can still make the mistake of being
somewhere you're not supposed to that's
but that doesn't make the god of
legitimate the way the right is making
him to be
right i never said he's here the kid is
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
would you go to somebody else's business
and protect him yeah i'm not talking
about whether or not he's a [ __ ] hero
i'm just saying that like oh listen i
could go somewhere i can go somewhere
legally where i shouldn't be
and and even have a gun with me maybe
that i should be able to have and
somebody could come out of nowhere and
try to kill me and i could defend myself
and and
end up killing them right and i could
still be i could be fine within my
rights to do that yeah but like
we might agree i actually think that on
one of the in one
two counts i think that some clever
lawyers
may actually be able to get an acquittal
i don't disagree with you on that i
actually
we might actually be on the same page as
far as that goes
yeah maybe yeah yeah i mean i think him
being there is dumb and then if he like
is carrying a weapon illegally or
whatever then that's also dumb as well
but the idea that
the thing is is that like this is
lagging a lot um most
unfortunately most people don't engage
in this conversation in good faith
anymore
um i i don't know if it's brain rot or
people are too ideologically driven
but the idea that a person who's in a
place that they're not supposed to be in
has to automatically die if somebody
tries to attack them and forfeits the
right to defend themselves
nobody truly believes that even people
that say they do they don't actually
believe that
and i would give the the underage girl
sneaking into a bar as my example every
time for that that if a girl goes into a
bar that she's not allowed in
and she carries like a knife with her to
protect herself and a guy tries to
sexually assault her and she ends up
killing the guy
nobody would say no one would say well
hold on that girl shouldn't have been in
there
that guy died and he shouldn't have died
no you would say okay she shouldn't have
been in there that's wrong maybe she
could even be charged for a fake id or
whatever but if there was a legitimate
use of self-defense is legitimately used
to self-defense yeah but that
i think unfortunately i i think we have
some points of agreement and some of
disagreement i think it's a bad analogy
and i'll tell you why
um if you just go into a bar
with the intent to get a drink when
you're 20 instead of 21
i think that that's both morally and
practically different
than going to some other state and
taking up guns illegally i think that
the
the idea that both are ostensibly
against the law
and but thus anything that follows still
has to be considered on a case-by-case
basis
is not a i don't think it's an
equivalent i don't think it's a good
equivalency
i don't think so if do you think it's
okay well then this might just come down
to it then then in that case it really
has nothing to do with the self-defense
whatever maybe just has to do with your
personal stance on guns
do you think it's okay to show up and
defend a business so that business calls
for help for people to show up and
defend a business against writers or do
you think that's immoral
i think that the question in the
abstract is not relevant to whether
17 year olds crossing state lines and
having guns illegally
that's different than an adult no who is
in the community and has the gun legally
i think they're two different things
before we talk about the specific
situation right we need a
fundamental understanding of how we feel
about these moral issues i actually
disagree so i actually i just i think we
should talk about that i disagree with
that because i think
the way that people end up taking
positions that in practice are misguided
is by ignoring the facts and saying
let's come up with
let's go to first principles and a
philosophical black hole about morality
i don't think that that's actually where
we should be starting
that that's absolute that is the only
place to start the reason why we
disagree well but i'm just right
i'm sorry like you you in order to
generate
consistent answers on a case
oh stephen you cut out there but it
sounded like you were saying that in
order to to be
to have consistent answers in individual
cases you need to first have
the uh the sort of um principles
straight but
that's how a lot of these right-wing i
actually i think uh you know
i i i love you but i do think others
would find it condescending for you to
say you're just right
i mean that that's we we have a
difference of opinion sure if you want
to have if you i'll say 20 000 dollars
on this conversation with any academic
in the world that knows anything about
forming arguments or philosophy relating
like you
you just you have to have first
principles before you go to practical
application like if you were to study
ethics applied ethics is downstream from
meta ethics and normative ethics
downstream yeah no i'm just saying that
i'm just saying that any individual
issue is going to be way downstream
from like like for instance should we
charge somebody with murder well in
order to know that you have to know is
murder right or wrong i don't know like
how do we consider what he's right or
wrong
by saying is it okay for him to go
across
lines and get a gun so what i'm trying
to figure out when you say that
what i'm trying to figure out is does
david think that defending property is
bad
or does he think that defending property
illegal is bad
or does he think that defending property
against certain people is bad i don't
know what your core principle that
you're like appealing to is that's why
i'm asking these hypotheticals
because i don't know when you say this
is a bad thing i'm trying to figure out
why you think it's a bad thing
and in order to know hypothetical to
figure out because let's
oh boy
and in xyz circumstances okay well then
let's
xyz circumstance that's what that's all
i'm trying to figure out is why you
think it's wrong or bad
i gotcha yeah i mean i think the so it's
appearing as though my internet
connection is not stable enough to
really do this in the detail we want to
do it in but i guess where i would want
to first start would be to explain that
the the context the idea of when is it
okay to defend stuff
is heavily connected to the context in
which it's happening
and at the core if i think of is this
it does does a 17 year old crossing
state lines
and illegally grabbing a gun to do these
defenses
does that get the country in the
direction i want it going in or not
that's where i would start it wouldn't
start with some vague is it okay to
defend
stuff it's like sure okay it is yeah
well sure do you think riots get the
country going in the direction that we
wanted to go no no
i don't okay do we think that telling
people that they have to submit their
property to destruction to violent mobs
gets us in the direction that we wanted
to go
well no and at the same time i'm worried
that
you are um indir
that that you're referring to something
specific which i may not even be
familiar with in order to get a general
answer
i'm just asking if there are rioters in
your city
do you think that you are obligated to
submit your property
to their whims that you have to stand by
and watch your business burn
in order for do you think that furthers
the country i i don't think it does but
it has nothing to do with whether i
should bring in 17 year olds from other
states to illegally have guns to help me
what if 17 year old some other states
are the only people that are willing to
show up and defend your stuff well
we could talk about that but that's
certainly not the
stephen stephen
oh boy steven listen let's when we when
we get back let me know when you can
hear me again stephen i don't think
that's what you care about
because what i'm curious is is if kyle
was 18 are you all of a sudden
completely 180 you know this you're like
oh well actually kyle was 100 on the
right
so if i tell you i also don't think 18
year olds should be crossing state lines
so this is this is why i say we need to
talk about first principles because
everything that you just said then is
irrelevant the fact that he's 17 doesn't
matter to you even if he was 18 you
still wouldn't like it so then we need
to talk about something else
17 is irrelevant but he is 17.
but it's but that's not the reason why
you're saying if this was if there's a
you're saying if there was a different
incident might i also be opposed to it
in that case
sure that's certainly possible but i'm
trying to figure out
why you're opposed to it here you're
saying like for instance
let's say somebody jaywalks and i said
that guy jaywalking
that was wrong because he was a white
guy that jaywalked and then i say
well wait so if he was black was it okay
and then you go no if he was black it's
wrong too
well then why is the fact that he's a
white guy joe why does that matter to
you
right when you bring that up it sounds
like that's one of the qualifying
reasons for why you're propelling it so
when you say he was eight under
17 and he did all these music oh you
just cut out
yeah you you you just cut out you just
cut out um
listen let's i think i think that with
that i think with the connection issues
it's hard for either of us to fully sort
of express our our points of view
but needless to say you know um it just
we it's like it sounds like you and i
maybe
came to a different conclusion about the
event but it's like it's not
a huge deal like i don't hate steven or
anything and i think people are
expecting some kind of
fireworks or whatever that uh it's just
not really how i
interact with people you know yeah no i
and what with you mean when [ __ ] is
lagging yeah exactly
hey listen i'm gonna yeah trump's about
to start so i'm gonna let you go my
connection is a disaster anyway
let's connect next week and really talk
about this in detail
yeah sure if you want to see it on your
next video cool all right man all right
all right take care bye see you all
right yeah i apologize guys i'm doing
the best i can i know people are mad at
me because of different things but i i'm
i'm really doing uh doing the best i can
here
and uh we're gonna we're gonna do our
best as donald trump gets ready to start
here
uh before we get to that i do have just
a really small thing to
i have a favor to ask of you i want you
to to help me with something
um if you want to help me get a better
internet connection
please consider grabbing a membership to
my website joinpakman.com no it's not
about the internet connection but in all
seriousness
our number one funding source are people
who sign up
at joinpakman.com you can see that above
my head
the coupon code is 2020 now
it saves you 66 if you hate me if you
hate this show
if you want to cancel me then don't help
don't sign up
it's easy uh if you do like this
and you believe that there's some value
here and most importantly if you can
afford a couple bucks a month
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com a
bunch of people have who i want to thank
david farruggia is new member number
three
tristan sergeant is new member number
four
susie carlson is new member number five
yvette
messar is new member number six
today and uh these memberships are
you know all of these other things
youtube and twitch and all of this
different stuff
those as revenue sources can be
irregular
membership is our funding source number
one let's go to trump
thank you
good afternoon hurricane sally made
landfall
as you know in alabama and florida last
night as
a category two hurricane and has caused
35 years
of rainfall in some places it's a lot a
lot
we have hundreds of fema coast guard we
have the national guard personnel
on the ground assisting response to the
efforts and alabama is in great shape
and
every place that we are working with the
state governments
really in great shape we are uh
working very hard on that but it looks
like it's going to be
mostly safe but just follow the
instructions of all of your local and
federal people there with the best
people that you can have so i want to
thank everybody i want to thank
everybody for working so hard in florida
and they're very good at this the people
in florida handle it they know how to
handle it and the people working there
know how to handle it
the governors have all been spoken to
and
uh it's a combination of real spirit
and they have a tremendous uh
esprit de corps escrita course a sense
of working on hurricanes they've gotten
very good at it
and we've certainly had plenty even
since i've been here we've had a lot of
them
so that's in good shape hurricane sally
everything's great
we're going to talk about big 10
football but that's a terrific
thing we'll discuss that at the end i
just want to go into the vaccine
distribution today my administration
released our detailed national vaccine
distribution plan
and that includes a plan to ensure that
we swiftly deliver the vaccine directly
to america's senior citizens
in nursing homes and it's all set we
have our military lined up everybody's
lined up just need a vaccine
and we think that's going to go very
nicely we're very close to that vaccine
as you know
and i think closer than most people want
to say or certainly closer than
most people understand to get the
vaccine into the hands of american
people we're fully mobilizing the
awesome power of
american industry and also our military
this is the largest fastest and most
advanced vaccine distribution effort in
american history
by far i was reading where biden was
saying that
oh he's going to have a plan they did so
bad on swine flu you wouldn't even
believe it
take a look at their record on swine flu
in fact the person that headed it up
said it was a total disaster
we're on track to deliver and distribute
the vaccine
in a very very safe and effective manner
we think we can start
sometime in october so as soon as it
is announced we'll be able to start
that'll be from mid-october on
maybe a little bit later than that but
we'll be all set so as soon as it's
given the go-ahead they're doing trials
as you know and as soon as it's given
they go ahead we will
get it out defeat the virus soon he'll
talk about biden being anti-vaxx right
supplies so that as soon as the fda
approves the
vaccine and as you know we're very close
to that we'll be able to distribute at
least 100 million vaccine doses by the
end of
2020 and a large number much
sooner than that i'm calling on
biden to stop promoting his anti-vaccine
theorists because alternating right on
cue the importance of what we're doing
and i know that if they were in this
position they'd be saying how wonderful
it is
yeah they're recklessly endangering
lives you can't do that
and again this is really a case that
they're only talking to just started
talking a little bit negatively and
that's only because they know we have it
or we will soon have it and the answer
to that is
very soon the
case updates it's very interesting to
see what's happening because the test
positivity rate
is down among all age groups and has
fallen below five percent for the first
time since
this whole nightmare of the china virus
began
so it's fallen below five percent the
number of hospitalized patients has
decreased by 43 percent
mid july 43 nationally people
sick with the china virus now make up
only 1.5 percent
of all emergency room visits so we're
down to the lowest number we've had 1.5
percent of emergency room visits
is for the china virus and thanks to our
life-saving therapies and treatments
i think this is the best of all in terms
of our great percentages and all the
progress
made the fatality rate has fallen 85
since april 85 fatality rate
a few now remember get that's case
fatality rate
relative to tests so it's not really a
reflection of how many people are dying
uh this was right at the beginning this
was our prediction that if we do a
really good job
we'll be at about a hundred and a
hundred thousand to two hundred and
forty thousand deaths
and we're below that substantially guys
he was
talking about 60k deaths months ago he's
now pretending all along the goal has
been to be below 240.
this guy is a liar 5 million i remember
these numbers so well in 2.2 million
you're remembering them wrong
that's quite a difference so we're down
in this territory
and that's despite the fact that the
blue states had
had tremendous death rates if you take
the blue states out we're
uh at a level that uh i don't think
anybody in the world yeah if you take
out old folks too
level but some of the states uh they
were blue states and blue state managed
and by the way we would recommend they
open up their states
states are open this this is maybe the
most dishonest we've seen him
because which says a lot certain of them
north carolina pennsylvania michigan
and a couple of others we have to get
those states open
it's hurting people it's hurting people
far more than the disease itself
wrong so we would recommend that you
open them let your people have freedom
states are open and it's unfair to your
people to keep them close at this stage
we know the vaccine we know the
vaccines are coming but we know the
problem trump doesn't seem to get it
just because restaurants are open
doesn't mean people are going to go
like the problem isn't that stuff is
closed gyms are open in massachusetts
nobody's going
indoor dining is open few people are
going open up your states
to facilitate routine testing of the
nursing home residents and staff we've
delivered rapid testing
devices to all one thousand or excuse me
13 850 certified nursing homes
nationwide
so you have 13 850
certified nursing homes nationwide and
they are
being facilitated in terms of testing
and testing
testing apparatus everything is there
we also have new tests coming and we
have one in particular that i think i
showed last night beautiful test which
is literally two pieces of
very fine cardboard it's actually a lot
of delicate
things going on inside that cardboard
but incredible test it's very quick it's
very accurate
and moves along rapidly we've bought
millions of those tests and they're
going to be distributed rapidly
sentimental testing process where
there's nobody in the world that has a
testing process like ours
in addition to being number one number
two which is india
is uh close to 50 million tests behind
us i believe it's got
50 million scottish 5 billion people
tomorrow vice president pence will be
announced when trump refers to scott
that scott atlas who wants to see us go
herd immunity about 2.4 million people
would die he's our senior citizens and
we're going to take good care of them
i want to congratulate big ten
football it's great it's back um and i
want to
in particular i've been dealing with him
thank commissioner kevin warren
for the great job he did we've been
working with him uh
for a while that there was a rumor being
does that happen one football back it
was just the opposite that was another
disinformation rumor put out by the
biden campaign
and it was just the opposite but it
really spurred me into action
i called the commissioner a couple of
weeks ago and we started really
putting a lot of pressure on frankly
because there was no reason for it not
to come back and
kevin went and worked very hard i want
to thank the players the coaches for
working along and they wanted it very
badly the players and coaches in
particular the parents
also and big ten football just announced
as you know that their schedule they
announced the schedule and it's going to
be great
important to have i want to recommend
that the pac-12 also get going because
there's no reason why pac-12
shouldn't be playing now and uh perhaps
they'll start with
at least partially i had recommended
today to
kevin and others that maybe you want to
start off with 25
of the stadium or maybe you want to
start off with empty i don't know if
it's i think they could have
fans go frankly but they want to be
careful they want to be safe and they
will be safe they've got a very
good testing process for the players
coaches families etc
and so i just want to congratulate big
ten
it's going to be great we're going to
love watching that and again i want to
recommend
pac-12 you're the only one now open up
open up pac-12
get going said the same thing to big ten
and they did
sports right that's what we need now you
have time
you really have time right now get going
i want to thank all of those
uh wonderful coaches some of whom i
spoke with
and we went through a process over the
last uh
couple of weeks and i want to thank
congressman anthony gonzalez of ohio
who is you know a football player some
people know that i know that
but anthony was a great player great
receiver
went to the nfl also i want to thank tim
pataki of my staff he worked very hard
on this and he was up day and night
working with kevin and everybody else so
i want to thank tim pataki great job
so big ten is back and it's gonna have
hopefully a great season
the census recently found that in the
second quarter of 2020
hispanic americans home ownership
reached a record all-time high
that's all time in the history of our
country yesterday the census reported
that median income for americans
increased by an unprecedented four
thousand four hundred dollars last year
to a record of sixty eight thousand
seven hundred dollars
in 2019 income inequality fell for the
second straight year
the income gap widened under the obama
biden administration and it widened
fairly substantially and it narrowed
under the trump administration so as a
little fact that you didn't know
a little factoid income grew more
last year alone than over the entire
eight years
of obama biden and uh
that's a big moment but that's the way
it is and 2019 4.2 million americans
were lifted out of poverty
that's the largest poverty reduction
under any president in history 4.2
million americans were lifted out of
poverty
the hispanic american poverty rate
reached the lowest level
ever history of our country hispanic
american poverty rate
lowest level ever i created the greatest
and fairest economy in history the
biggest gains went to lower income
americans
as they measure that kind of thing we
will
be back to full strength very soon we're
going to have a fantastic year next year
yeah trump spent about five minutes on
college football let's see uh
you know would be great to hear them
talk about fires for a few minutes
a quarter we have numbers that we're
going to put out tomorrow some of the
individual things
car production housing production
housing ownership so many different
things are just
at levels that nobody thought possible
as we round the turn on the pandemic
the anti-police crusade
from the democrats and the radical left
and radical left democrats also has to
stop
the left-wing war on cops puts our
officers in
danger communities at very grave risk
he's off to
do this biden described the police as
the enemy
they're not the enemy they're the friend
they're our friend they're helping us
and if you go to i just saw a poll
just came out or recently came out where
african americans
by 84 wanted more police
they wanted safe neighborhoods in
phoenix last night a federal officer was
gunned down in a drive-by shooting
in la this weekend everybody saw that
this horrible human being or
whatever you might want to call him
[Laughter]
they're looking all over they're trying
to find him
we're going to find out we're going to
get them but in la this weekend two
sheriffs
deputies were ambushed and viciously
shot and they can never be the same
they're getting better but they can
never be the same
i'll always stand by our heroes of law
enforcement
and we want to stop this horrible
rhetoric and stop it fast
i want to ask uh scott atlas to say a
couple of words oh
no because i heard biden talking today
about
uh he wants to come up with a
distribution plan a distribution for the
vaccine that we came up with
trump didn't come up with any vaccines
you know that it'll be announced fairly
soon but
regardless this month next month
in a level of time that nobody thought
was possible because of what we did with
our fda in terms of streamlining it i
want to thank thank dr han
but what we've done with the
streamlining has been incredible
and very safely number one is safety
number two is speed but
you can have perfect safety and have
much more speed and that's what we did
we did this
for more than the vaccine having to do
with the china viruses was
also for other things yeah so many other
great drugs are out there that would
take
10 12 years to get them approved and
we've moved those schedules up
i hope you guys know that you know
there's a difference between an
emergency use authorization and an
actual approval
that relevant distinction two three
years before you were at a stage
where we are now at so we're going to be
very soon and
it's sort of funny to watch uh
joe biden getting up and reading a
teleprompter and saying how
how he would have uh done this they had
h1 n1 he calls it the n1h1
it's h1n1 it's called the swine flu
and it was a disaster and as i said the
person that ran it for him said
the worst things about it i mean just
they didn't know what they were doing
they
quit they had they had no clue and that
was easy by comparison to this
there's the most contagious contagious
flu or virus that
oh
oh boy had anybody seen this is
unbelievable how contagious
but we do indeed our military
oh god the pictures we have everybody
involved
it's uh it's a great plan
and it's a plan like no other and we can
start doing it i believe the day that we
come up with a vaccine when it's
done we'll start that same day or the
day after
our military is very much involved and
they deploy troops they deploy these are
the generals that
that do logistics and all of those
things and we'll have it
all over the country those are the
generals he called [ __ ] according to
bob woodward
a vaccine and it's very exciting but
maybe i'd ask god atlas to come up and
describe a little bit about
that at the distribution plan in
particular because
biden acted as though there was no
distribution
plan and we've been working on this for
months and it's ready and scott has
really taken a hold of it and done an
incredible job
and uh please scott thank you
downer trump today very down okay thank
you
thank you mr president and i didn't
develop the plan i'm just relaying
information yeah and trump didn't
develop the vaccine either
this is a plan that's a 57-page document
that was sent to every state
today and there's a uh different uh
part of this that was given to congress
today uh
it was released by hhs it's on the
website
and in fact i thought it was covered
actually by the media so i don't think
it's a surprise but it's a comprehensive
plan
it's a public-private partnership to get
everything done in terms of logistics
the i.t that's necessary to trace
the first dose because some of these
vaccines are anticipated to be
two doses there's tailoring of course by
the states and their specifics and
there's an administration of the vaccine
plan
that will be done in over 51 000 outlets
including
uh for particular attention to minority
areas
over fourteen thousand uh federally
qualified
health centers and as the president just
said within the first 24 hours of fda's
approval
under an emergency use we will have
vaccines being delivered within the
first 24 hours notice how they
so trump never trump talks about
approval this guy actually feels
compelled to throw in
under emergency use and that's why
people are skeptical
uh there will be and is it anticipated
uh
that no later than january all the top
priority
uh people will have received the vaccine
or be able to receive the vaccine
and so that kind of prioritization which
is the general prioritization done
for all vaccines that are developed
particularly in a pandemic setting
it goes to the high risk people the
people with
other underlying conditions as well as
first responders and people working
directly in health care
and so that's can be done very rapidly
okay
good thank you thank you
mr president earlier today dr redfield
confirmed that it looked like november
december the first doses would be able
to be
distributed but then he said that the
vaccine from the general public
likely would not be available until
probably next summer maybe even early
fall
are you comfortable with that no i think
he made a mistake when he said that
right it's just incorrect information
and i called him
and he didn't tell me that and i think
he got the message maybe confused maybe
he was confused incorrectly no we're
ready to go immediately just chalk it up
to confusion guys
announced and it could be announced in
october could be announced a little bit
after
october but uh once we go
we're ready uh as you know fizer's
making
this they're taking a tremendous
financial visa and they're
spending billions of dollars on actually
making this vaccine they're in a stage
where they're actually
making it because they feel very
confident as to the results they'll be
announcing their results fairly soon
and no he's uh that's incorrect
information
he was clear in the way yeah well i
think so but i don't think he
means that i don't think he when he said
it
i believe he was confused i'm just
telling him we're ready to go as soon as
the vaccine
guys we've got about everything's good
the guy running the cdc was just
confused
yeah we will start distributing it
immediately
to the general public very shortly there
i mean it really to the general public
immediately when we go we go we're not
looking to say gee in six months we're
going to start giving it to the general
public no we want to go immediately no
it was an
incorrect statement i saw the statement
i called him i said what did you mean by
that
and i think he just made a mistake
he just made a mistake but what have you
misunderstood the question probably
so if you were to put a timeline on when
every person in america
will be able to get a vaccine what would
that be i think it would be
very soon i think our distribution
process is going to go very quickly
this is how you know he's lying the
military we have a general who's in
charge of all logistics who
delivers soldiers he's deliver soldiers
12 soldiers please all men oh yeah yeah
two-day
company you're gonna hire you can't hire
a company like that and
i we look to uh do distribution
immediately after we get the word that
it's good
and i think they're having tremendous
success with the vaccine itself
i think the results will be early and
strong the safety has to be a hundred
percent and we're going to
insist on that and obviously the
companies are going to insist on that
also
could you put an actual day but january
what would you think
yeah uh the as i said the high priority
people
uh will have sure in some time no later
than january
i mean of course it depends on when
things are approved in the emergency
room
i'm talking about this i can finish uh
and then there's anticipated there will
be 700 million
doses by end of q1 at 700 million doses
so by the end of the month that's on the
cube one dr
ellis do you mind if i ask you one easy
yeah that's the end of our trip
it's one thing to have the doses we've
talked to a lot of public health
q1 of which year happening in the winter
and you have to socially distance
you can't have the packed lines that we
saw during h1n1
you can't have packed auditoriums you
have to space it out
so that's one thing i thought another
thing they're worried about
is storing these vaccines and since we
don't know these people are such liars
it's unbelievable
doctors offices may not have dry ice to
handle negative 80 degrees so these are
challenges are you prepared to
say that oh yeah overcome all those in
three months oh yeah
yes because uh at least i've been
briefed on the vaccine okay and so
all the refrigerators that are necessary
everything is going to be in place for
this
there's a very detailed logistical plan
that was started months ago
and you know you're welcome to read it
on the web but basically yeah
all those things are not a problem
really i mean if people know how to shop
for groceries or go into a store or sit
in the restaurants that are open and use
social distancing i think they can do it
for vaccines too
and you also have more than one company
you have johnson and johnson you have
pfizer you have
moderna you have others so we could
conceivably have vaccines
being given out by numerous companies
and they're all world-class companies
they're fantastic companies
that could happen also okay yeah please
go ahead
thank you mr president are you prepared
to sign off on the oracle and title deal
even though the
treasury isn't getting paid and also
does the deal meet your requirements in
terms of national security concerns
remember trump wanted like 40 million
from that deal or something
as far as national security is concerned
and uh
no i'm not prepared to sign off on
anything i have to see the deal
we need security especially after what
we've seen with respect to china and
what's going on
we want security so i'll let you know
they're going to be reporting to me
tomorrow morning
and i will let you know
what about the payments of the treasury
well we're going to see about that uh
amazingly i find that you're not allowed
to do that you're not allowed to accept
money so what kind of a government what
kind of
that thing trump's been talking about
for months taking a cut of a deal
between two private companies turns out
you're not allowed to do that who
knew who are you there's no legal path
to doing that
wait a minute they're willing to make a
big payment to the government and we're
not allowed to take the money when does
this happen
how foolish can we be so we're gonna
we're looking into that
right now you understand that sounding
like socialism guys
chunk of that money to go to the united
states government because we made it
possible
and the lawyers come back to me and they
say well there's no way of doing that
that's right you know why because
nobody's ever heard of that before
nobody well
socialist countries have he's ever said
well we'll approve the deal
but we want a lot of money to go to the
guy mob bosses have
making the deal valuable they've never
heard of that before
okay can you believe that right yeah
hard to believe yeah
a quick follow-up on tick-tock you had
said earlier that it was really
important to you that a u.s company
buy tick-tock and according to the
proposal submitted by
fight dance fight dance would keep a
majority stake and oracle would have
a minority well we're going to find out
about that we're looking into that from
the standpoint of bite dance we don't
like that i've been just
it's conceptually i can tell you i don't
like that it's too good
that has not been told to me yet that
has been reported but hasn't been told
to me it could be very accurate
reporting for a change
so if that's the case i'm not going to
be happy with it ah assuming that white
dances china which i think it probably
is yeah
yeah in the background yeah thanks
president um bill barr told prosecutors
that he wants to charge violent
demonstrators with uh with sedition
and you told judge jeanine that there's
violent demonstrations on election night
we'll put them down very quickly if they
do that look it's called an insurrection
so i'm wondering why you want to use
that kind of rhetoric when there's such
a well the question was asked to me
about if you have violent demonstrations
yes
we will put it down very very quickly if
there is
absolutely are you making that and i
think the american public wants to see
that
yeah oh here we go oh yeah yeah
thank you mr president um
if there's any kind of demonstration or
violence there will be nothing that
interferes with this project product
this this vote there's going to be
nothing the biggest
problem we have right now are the
ballots
millions of ballots going out that's the
biggest problem when you talk about
other countries whether it's china
russia or
many others who get mentioned they're in
a much better position with these paper
ballots
to do something than they would ever be
under the old system
and that's our biggest problem our
biggest threat to this election
is uh governors from opposing parties
controlling ballots millions of ballots
to me that's a much bigger threat than
foreign countries
because much of the stuff coming out
about foreign countries turned out to be
untrue
what is what is true is that many
elections have taken place over the last
year and a half using this ballot system
they've been off by 5 10 15
i think i read one at 40 percent 40
and these are small easy to control
elections
this whole ballot system where you can
send it in
and it's not even requested we're not
talking about it solicited
their unsolicited ballots and they're
sent in
is very dangerous for our country and
you know who knows that better than
anybody
the democrats look at what happened in
manhattan
where they had this kind of an election
remember there's no fraud even alleged
in that election
that it should never have been allowed
to be called we could have five
10 15 20 off we could have more than
that
the ballots will be stolen who knows
where they're going
right who knows where they're coming
from
just the counting of the ballots which
by the way which will take forever
it'll take forever you think november
3rd you might not have
i guess at a certain point it goes to
congress you know at a certain point
it goes to congress that wouldn't be
until january you're going to have
four days you'll have the election
results and who cares i'd rather have
the right results
it's going to be fraud all over the
place who's getting the ballots who's
sending the ballots
they have people saying you don't need a
verified signature
this is a serious threat to a democracy
and the democrats know that
all we're asking if you solicit the
ballot
you go through a process you ask for a
ballot because you can't be there
uh for a large number of reasons
for whatever i'm doing it myself we know
i won't be able to be in florida
right you solicit and they send it back
you do it and you send it back that's a
process that you go through
and it's pretty secure i see you the
word pretty secure i guess
nothing's foolproof but what's pretty
close to what
the most foolproof thing the thing that
really
uh works is you go to the
ballot box it's going to be very safe i
think by that time covett will be
even lower it's going to be very low
it's going to be a very safe process
we did it during world war one we did it
during world war
ii the biggest threat to this election
is these huge numbers of mail-in ballots
during world war one actually if
anything world war one proves
our case not his owners like in nevada
who is a political person very political
but far beyond being governor
where they tried to stop you from making
a speech
unsuccessfully but we had to move around
a lot had to move quickly
so this same guy that tried to stop you
from making free speech
outside outside they forced us inside
because of what they did
but outside this is the guy that's
controlling ballots
then you look at pennsylvania you look
at other places
it is a big threat and as far as china
is concerned and russia and
they say north korea they say iran they
say places who knows
who knows but they say all these
different places
they can make forgeries of these ballots
they can do things that will blow your
mind
and the democrats know it's wrong they
know it's going to end up being a
disaster
just take a look at what's happened take
a look at what's happened over the last
year with
this same kind of thing except what's he
talking about
with very few ballots going out so
that's much easier
not 53 to 80 million
going out a very small number and you
know what's happened
fraud like you've never seen missing
ballots
ballots that never showed up balanced
with bad signatures ballots with no
signatures
and in the case of nevada they don't
even want verification of this i think
signage is
is my favorite the hope for our nation
is
it's before judges in pennsylvania it's
before judges in nevada's
before judges well ultimately i predict
donald trump is going to try to sue to
stop the counting of absentee ballots
starting on november 4th so it could end
up back before judges and that's why
biden's got to mount
the legal team that he's mounting as i
suggested he do
is closing it and they're closing it for
political reasons
it'll open on november 4th it'll open up
right after the election
no but they want people to they want our
numbers to be as bad as possible but the
problem is our numbers are so good with
or without various states opening up
with or without but we had a big legal
victory as you know three days ago
a federal judge told them to open up
their state
it's unconstitutional what you're doing
that's in the case of pennsylvania
now the big cases are going to be the
cases on these
unsolicited ballots and we'll see what
happens right oan please
here we go the chinese communist party
has been using slave later in xinjiang
your administration
later that was a limited ban on certain
products coming out of xinjiang
stopping short of a full region ban um
what is your response to the chinese
communist party
spokespeople who are saying that this is
an outright lie xinjiang does not have
forced labor and number two have allies
expressed interest in standing
with this administration in taking
action against forced labor
we don't want to see that we've been
very strong on that we're getting
reports and over the next two three days
we'll know very accurately what the
story is and
until then take action one way or the
other
yes i just want to ask you about the
wto's recent ruling against the united
states over 200 billion in tariffs on
china
should the u.s remain part of the let's
maybe just switch to our other feed
where we can see the reporters it might
be better see that
we've been very strong on that we're
getting reports in over the next two
three days we'll know very accurately
what the story is and
will then take action one way or the
other
yes i just want to ask you about the
wto's recent ruling against the united
states over 200 billion in tariffs on
china
should the u.s oh guess they're not
cutting to the report
of the wto well i have real questions
about it look the us
we just won a seven and a half billion
dollar lawsuit
um which nobody used to sue before i
came along you know well they used to
lose them every single
time now they haven't been losing them
but we're getting reports on the wto
it's uh it's um not good
never been good to us the wto
as far as i'm concerned was created to
suck money and jobs out of the united
states to the benefit of china and other
countries that's what
my opinion is whether it was created or
it just turned out to be that way
but the world trade organization has
been
not good for the united states it's been
good for everybody else but it's not
been good
it was uh a method in my opinion of
taking advantage of the united states
so we're looking into what happened and
we'll let we'll get back to you
you said you spoke with dr redfield
earlier and you said that he made a
mistake
i think he made a mistake yeah we didn't
i didn't go anything
i was i was very surprised to hear it it
doesn't really matter
here's what does matter we're all set to
distribute immediately
as soon as that vaccine comes out that's
safe and good and works whether it's
fizer johnson or johnson or anybody else
we're ready to distribute it very
rapidly as scott said
and as our team knows and they're ready
and that could be on
it could be in october sometime in
october or november
i don't think it's going to be much
later than that but i think it could be
sometime in october
we're ready to move and it'll be a very
full distribution
y'all had the call you said that you
told him that he made a mistake
what was his response no i didn't tell
him anything i said what happened
and i got the impression that he didn't
realize he said what he
might have said i didn't see him saying
if that's what he said it's a mistake
because he's
so ready we're ready to distribute
immediately
to a vast section of our
country and then beyond unintelligible
we want to help other countries also
unintelligible we're ready to distribute
immediately but the timeline that he
gave saying that it would be ready for
the general public until the middle next
year it sounds
very like the one that you kind of just
offered no no i said that there'll be
700 million doses by end of q1
and everyone in high risk will have it
sometimes
no later than jen yeah he was talking
about the general public
we are focused as you know caitlin we're
focused on high risk but we're going to
focus also on general public very much
but we are
our immediate aim is elderly people
and especially elderly people with i'd
love for someone to actually say
q1 of which year this is we're not
looking at a small
uh distribution program we're looking at
distributing to the whole united states
with an
immediate focus of the elderly now
uh under no circumstance will it be
as late as the doctor said
but uh i think that which doctor
if he analyzes you know they hit him
with that question he said that
we are ready at a much faster level
than what he said we will have rapid
distribution
we're set up our military and others are
set up to do it
and we think it could even start taking
place in october but
certainly during november december would
be the latest
because based on what we're hearing uh
results are
based on what i'm hearing results are
very good so we'll see what happens you
told bob woodward
the problem with a vaccine is a vaccine
will take 13 to 14 months once you have
it because you have to test a vaccine
so do you want to clean what i was what
i was saying to him no
that was a long time ago when i said
that i didn't we weren't set up at that
time
well how many months ago when was the
statement made you know his book was
sort of obsolete because the book
she said 13 to 14 months when we have it
very rapidly because it was very boring
i read it and if you see what i said i
said a lot of really good things i mean
for the most part
people like to turn it around but i said
really good things in that book and as
an example
he doesn't cover i told him what we're
doing in the middle east oh no and we're
doing it
in an entirely different way and that's
not covered
in his book the whole thing isn't
covered in his book and one thing i will
say and i respect the press for this one
which was interesting
almost universally we've been praised
for the deal that we made
yesterday with israel and with you know
two very important
countries in the middle east e in
particular where
it's a very powerful group it's a
warrior country it's led by a
a great warrior and a warrior who's
highly respected and
if you take a look at that and bahrain
and israel making a deal and i will tell
you we have at least four or five
others that want to come in they would
have come in yesterday i talked to two
of them yesterday and they're ready to
trot and uh i think you're going to have
a whole
level of peace without blood all over
the sand nobody was shot nobody was
killed
hundreds of thousands of people in the
middle east it's all it's been
now you might be saying what problem was
there between israel and uae and that
would be a beautiful question to ask
the world and it didn't have to be that
way the single worst decision
our country ever made was to go into the
middle east
not only the millions of people killed
and i include people on both sides you
know some people say oh you shouldn't
say that i said i'll say it
on both sides such a horrible thing was
done such a horrible mistake was
horrible
we're doing this a different way so we
have those two countries we have
at least five that we're negotiating
with right now
you know you can only negotiate with so
many i think they're all going to come
in
uh i think ultimately uh the power too
many negotiations
these are all the people that are
funding them you know i stopped funding
the palestinians
fairly early on because they were saying
bad things about our country i said we
mean we're giving them 750
millions a year and they're saying all
bad things about our country
so i stopped funding them very early on
but they get funded by other very rich
countries to them it's like a spec it's
nothing
but they get funded and uh but i think
now that these countries these very rich
countries
are uh part of the deal and they're
gonna you'll see
over the next fairly short period of
time very strong other countries will
come in
i think saudi arabia ultimately will
come in too
i think getting saudi arabia will be
great but i think saudi arabia is my
feeling
it's not based on knowledge other than a
couple of conversations i had with the
king
but saudi arabia i think will be coming
listen i've seen some interviews with
with saudi royals recently i'm not
seeing anybody too ready to recognize
israel's mere existence never mind do
whatever trump is imagining
smart people i went to some people in
the middle east and they said you'll
never be able to do it it's not possible
to make peace well
now they're saying to me nobody ever
thought of doing this
they all thought yeah well because these
were two countries that were doing okay
and i will say the resistance was some
countries didn't want to do it unless
the palestinians were there first that
was just a psychological thing more than
anything else psychology
those guys the people our
uh great representatives that have been
doing this for 35 years that were
telling me how to do it
but they all failed they were in
clinton's administration they were in
bush they were in
uh obama all these great brilliant
people
they're all telling me how to do it and
i said they're wrong and i guess i was
right
and when you see let me just let's talk
finish this
when you see the countries that will be
coming a very short period of time not
talking in a long period of time
all of the countries that will be coming
in just like you saw bahrain yesterday
and uh uae and uh
i can think of i mean at least five that
are going to be
quick and easy others will be quick and
easy also once the five comes it comes
like the fast food equivalent of a peace
deal
peace in the middle east and we want to
get out you know we want to
our soldiers are largely coming home i
said the endless wars the ridiculous
endless wars
and i will say this if i didn't withdraw
our country from that horrible
iran nuclear deal that horrible stupid
deal
where president obama paid 150 billion
dollars for nothing and gave 1.8
billion dollars in cash 1.8 billion you
know what that is
1.8 billion in cares that's more
impressive than the 150 billion
paid normally but he gave all this money
all of this uh all of these chips that
we had we had these chips and he gave
them all
and we got nothing and you know it was a
short-term deal it would be practically
expiring now
we practically it starts to expire
actually right now but it would
practically be
and there is no way we will let iran
have a nuclear weapon
just remember that there's no way that's
going to happen
okay just look up this but do you want
to reverse what you told woodward about
the 13 to 14 month
timeline for a vaccine well the vaccine
at the time i
thought it might take that period of
time but we've stepped it up very
substantially and now i mean i'm just
telling you
this is just what it is we've been able
to step it up very very rapidly
i never thought we could have a vaccine
as quickly as we did but i freed it up i
freed up the fda
dr hans done a great job what he means
is he's encouraged them to approve
things that aren't ready
the other thing that's happening that's
very different is you look at a company
like fisa
great company really one of the great
companies of the world johnson and
johnson they're all
great companies they're doing a lot of
testing at a very rapid rate that
nobody's ever seen anything like it you
know they're out in third
they're in the third level of trial and
level of trial we call it phase three in
the medical world
when i made statements like that that's
an old statement
when i made statements like that i had
no idea that we could produce as well as
we're producing
but only because of what i've done with
the fda and other things
can we come up with numbers like that
we're lucky that we don't have to
because that was considered fast
if this were a an administration from
the past and i think i can say
far beyond obama it was other
administrations also
you wouldn't have a vaccine for two and
a half three years and we're going to
have a vaccine within
at most a couple of months okay
mr president if i could ask you about
coronavirus relief do you support the
problem solvers caucus proposal
that was put forward are you comfortable
with the fight something like that
what's happening with the second i like
the larger amount i've said that you
know some of the republicans
disagree but i think i can convince them
to go along with that because i like the
larger number
uh i want to see people get money i want
to see it wasn't their fault that this
happened it was china's fault you know
people say oh maybe you shouldn't say
that that's not nice it was china's
fault
so i'd like to see the larger number
yeah i would like to see it
there are some things i disagree with
but i'm sure they can be negotiating
now i heard nancy pelosi said she
doesn't want to leave until we have an
agreement she's come a long way that's
great
if she said that she's come a long way
i agree with her we should have an
agreement people should be helped
and they should be helped as rapidly as
possible and i think it's going to
happen
i think it's very important so the
problem solvers came up with it's a
group of
people in congress as you know you know
them all i know them all they're very
good people i guess you'd consider
but in many cases they're not they're
left they're right but they came up with
this idea
and i think they're well on their way to
suggesting some pretty good things yeah
i agree with a lot of it in terms of
things that you don't agree are you
comfortable with the 500 i think
the things i don't agree we can probably
negotiate but i think we've made some
progress over the last week
and i think it was positive that they
came out with that report just to button
this up would you endorse that proposal
well
not that a proposal but we're getting
closer we're getting closer
i do like a lot of money getting sent to
people that
really were really were hurt
unnecessarily by china because they
could have stopped it they stopped it
from
going into their country they could have
stopped it from coming to our country
and from going to europe and from going
to
the rest of the world 188 different
countries from all over the world please
president the director of the cdc also
testified today
that a mass in his estimation is is
guaranteed to protect the american
public
more from the chronovirus than a vaccine
now you have as
detailed poured a lot of resources into
a vaccine development
why not devote your masks why not devote
your energy now to a campaign to have
all americans wear a mask something that
if
if more effective than a vaccine would
also help the schools in the economy
number one is not more effective by any
means than a vaccine and i called him
about that though
and i believe that uh if you ask him
he would probably say that he didn't
understand the question
because i said to mason those two
questions this redfield guy doesn't
understand a damn thing according to
trump
and uh and i was inaccurately covered
because i was on with george last night
george
stephanopoulos and uh i enjoyed it i
think
people enjoyed it i got you know a lot
of people said very good things about
the show
i hope they did well but they said a lot
of good things about the show but they
always cut my sentences off you know
they cut it off
on masks some asks have problems too
about
the masks have to be handled very gently
very carefully
uh i see that they could explode if
mishandled
and they're playing around with their
mask and they have it their fingers are
in their mask and then they're serving
with plates i mean i think there's a lot
of
problems with masks no vaccine is much
more effective than the max and if we
get the vaccine we have
uh added to the fact that our numbers
are going way down you know you see the
numbers i'm just reading you statistics
that are
from wherever they get them but they're
very highly uh
qualified statistics but no the mask is
not as important as the vaccine the va
the mask perhaps helps don't forget a
lot of people didn't like the concept of
masks initially dr fauci didn't like him
and
a lot of people didn't i'm not knocking
anybody because i understand both
sides of the argument but when i called
up uh
i said to him uh what's with the mask he
said i think i answered that question
incorrectly i think maybe he had
misunderstood it i mean you know you
have two
questions maybe he misunderstood both of
them right but the
answer to the one is it's going to be a
much faster distribution than he said
maybe he's not aware of the distribution
process it's not really his thing as
much as it would be let's say mine but
the distribution is going to be much
faster as far as the mask is concerned
i hope that the vaccine is going to be a
lot more beneficial than the masks
because people have used the masks
but when i looked at that chart that we
put up if you look
you know we're right if you do the good
job they had i guess 240
000 but if you do the good if if it
worked out well now look
one death is too much one death is too
much should have never happened
but the lower level was at that 240 000
between 100 and something and 240 it was
60 he said as far as the mask is
concerned he made a mistake
perhaps they are part of the role for
the decrease in cases that
because they are affected as you just
said so i know you've learned they may
be effective
and i wear them when i'm in a hospital
or when i'm in a setting with a lot of
questions
why not wear more often or have the
white house stack wear more often to set
an example for the country
well i'm tested and i'm sometimes
surprised when i see somebody sitting
and
like with uh joe joe feels very safe in
a mask i don't know maybe he doesn't
want to expose
his face i don't know what's going on
he'll be way away from people
nowhere near god leaders there'll be
nobody with them he's sending around
crowds setting up samples these big
circles they'll be way far away
there's no reason for him to have masks
on we get tested i'm tested i have
people tested when people come into the
oval office it's like a big deal no
matter who they are the heads of
countries they all get tested
so i'm in sort of a different position
uh and maybe if i wasn't in that
position i'd be wearing it
more but i've worn masks and especially
i like to wear them when i'm in hospital
not for me so much as for other people
okay thanks
uh
uh dr atlas you mentioned uh minorities
would be the first
focus of the distribution how would that
exactly work in practice when did he say
that
specifically to minorities i didn't hear
him say that he didn't seminar he says
minorities and senior citizens yes
but uh can you talk us through a bit
more on that did he say minor i didn't
hear him say that
how that would work and then for you mr
president uh you mentioned the drop in
the poverty rate
specifically we noticed at just the news
that the poverty rate for african
americans hit historic lows
that the household wealth increased
historically for african americans
what was driving that increase in wealth
for african americans and now in 2020
this is like north korea guys at this
point is these these staged questions
sycophants from the back question i
appreciate your question and yeah we've
had a tremendous drop in poverty
for all people in our nation but
in particular for african americans and
that statistic came in and it's because
uh the african-american community the
black community has had
the lowest the best employment numbers
that we've ever had both employment
and unemployment depending on how you
want to define it but we've had the best
employment numbers we've ever had now we
had the
employment in the country ever almost
160 million people we've never been
close to that number but we were
just six months ago and uh yeah
the i'm very proud of the numbers
african-americans hispanic americans
they had the best numbers they've ever
had by far
both employment and unemployment
depending on definition
uh thank you very much for that question
scott do you want to answer that yeah
so what i to clarify said that the first
prioritization
is the high-risk people and front-line
health care workers
but just to reiterate what i said there
are 51 000 outlets for
for uh distribution for for vaccination
and there's over 14 000 federally
qualified health centers that are
particularly targeted to minority and
low income
areas so that that's a focus i want to
point out two other things
we're also prioritizing testing
historically black colleges and
universities
and we're in the process of getting that
finalized because we know that there's
high
higher morbidity within certain ethnic
groups
and the last thing i would say is uh
it's protectiveness
and egregious abuse of the media to
instill fear
in oh god about taking a vaccine because
there is no shortcut here
everything is safe everything is
effective and for people who have
particularly an influence this guy's
saying even though i'm a herd immunity
advocate trust me there's a particularly
you know outrageous
abuse of public policy of leadership
these are people that have higher risk
higher and so i implore everyone's in a
high risk
category that when we get a safe
effective vaccine
they should take the vaccine i will say
this is a phenomena that only happened
when they realized that we may very well
have
the vaccine prior to a certain very
important date
november 3rd once they heard that the
democrats started
just to show you how bad no it started
when trump said we might push this out
via emergency youth
use authorization information
just like they put an ad in about
football just like they put
with respect to me i'm the one that got
football back and i was always against
them
going out it was ridiculous that big ten
and now hopefully pac-10 goes back and i
say that
just like even worse they put out a
totally
fake ad totally made up stores a made-up
story by a third-rate magazine
where the head guy i guess the head
person
i have no idea who he is i don't know
but he's friends with
obama and clinton so they made up this
horrible story and then they did ads
well they made up this story too this
story is very simple
they started knocking the vaccine as
soon as they heard that this actually
may come out prior to election
now it may or may not but it'll be
within a matter of weeks
it'll be within a matter of weeks from
november it's ready to go and it's ready
for massive distribution to everybody
with a focus again on
seniors and i will say also the
historically
black colleges and universities we
are doing at my suggestion because they
have had
a difficult problem there we are doing
more testing there and
finer testing we have our our great
apparatus there
operating when you look at what we've
done on testing in terms of the
technology and the amount it's been
really amazing in fact i think we're
going to crack 100 million tests very
soon in the very near future we're going
to be cracking 100 million tests
now what that does do is it shows up
more cases if we didn't test we wouldn't
have cases you would have no cases other
countries they don't test they don't
have cases
beautiful and then they say oh the
united states well uh but we're proud of
it because it shows
where there may be a problem and it
helps people but we're doing
tremendous testing at the historically
black
colleges and universities and that was a
suggestion i made and i think it's a
good
i think it's a good suggestion yeah
please go ahead yes
thank you um the core of vice president
biden's argument
is that you don't trust the scientists
you don't listen to them
and here up on the podium today you're
twice contradicting
the director of your own cdc on this who
testified before congress today no he's
contradicting himself
i think he misunderstood the question
well he was testifying you know what i
think
i think he misunderstood i told you i
don't have to go through this i think
you misunderstood the questions but i'm
telling you
this is the bottom line distribution is
going to be if your cdc director can't
even understand
questions about the things he's working
on every day you've got a problem with
your cdc director right
yeah distribution is going to be very
rapid and the vaccine is going to be
very powerful it's going to solve a
tremendous problem
it's going to be very powerful the
american people trust you
on the pandemic when you're
contradicting the head of the cdc
because of the great job we've done
because of the great things we've done
in
other fields also because of the fact
that we created ventilators we built
ventilators by the thousands and now
we're supplying to the world
because of all of the incredible work
we've done for governors
who are on every call saying this is
incredible this is great this is great
sometimes they're not quite as friendly
at a news conference when you have
people covering it but we have done a
phenomenal job on covet 19 as they like
to call it
i call it other things but we have done
a phenomenal job
i get calls from other people in other
countries they can't believe the job
we've done
and then they'll say is there any way
that you could get us ventilators i say
how many do you need
1 000 ventilators i said we'll be able
to take care of it
we're making thousands of ventilators
very complex very expensive very
difficult thing to make
we're making thousands a month the
cupboard was bare when i got here
and i will tell you our distribution is
going to be very rapid and very
it's going to be all-encompassing we are
going to have a focus on certain groups
that have
problems senior citizens etc but it's a
very powerful
it's a it's going to be a very powerful
distribution it's going
to cover everybody and it's going to
cover them rapidly i don't know whether
or not the doctor
knows that how much he covers but i
called him
oh
because i said why did you say that long
he wasn't that aware of it and the other
one was the mask
the vaccine is going to have tremendous
power it's going to be extremely strong
it's going to be extremely successful
we're not going to have a problem and
the mask may help
and i hope it helps i think it probably
does
but again the mask is a mixed bag there
are some people
professionals scott you would know a lot
of them but there are some people that
don't like the mask because of the
touchiness and the touching and then
you're touching everything else
they have they feel that masks have
problems so anyway go ahead in the
background
uh he sort of i think maybe
misunderstood a question
but we're beyond that so we're really in
final stages of
vaccines we're getting ready to go phase
one on distribution
and i think it might come out even
sooner than you think
uh i think the vaccine's going to be
even better than people thought
originally i think people
are going to be really surprised at the
success of the vaccine i think it's
going to be a tremendous success
shocked and we're fighting a very
powerful party
with a poor candidate in my opinion but
we're fighting a very
very powerful party and they're partners
with the
media and because they're working
together very closely
and they only started hitting on the
vaccine when they hit on the vaccine
they only hit on it when they realized
that wow
this is amazing they may have it even
before the election all of a sudden they
didn't like the vaccine so much
and the back place thank you so much mr
president where are you
informed about positive coronavirus
cases
were you informed about coronavirus
cases positive cases
in the white house today about today
yes understand this understanding today
[Music]
i heard about it this morning at a very
small level yes i heard about it this
week
i don't know we can have a report to you
if you feel it's necessary but it's a
small it's last night i heard about it
for the first time
oh he said this morning it's a small
number of cases maybe it's not even
cases do you know do you have any idea
if there's
yes yeah that's okay
yes but um it did not affect the event
and press was not around
uh the industry and it's not anybody
that was near me
most importantly from what i heard a
very small number i think you can
probably give the number out later on
when you find out what it might be
one person it was one person okay in
philadelphia it was one person
that's so not too much not a person that
i was associated with most important
thank you very much everybody
thank you thank you much there it is
donald trump will sort of uh
stalk his way out of the region of
another one of these
very very belligerent press conferences
listen
if you're heading out and you're
watching on youtube
please make sure to hit that subscribe
button helping us
work our way to 1.1 million subscribers
if you're watching on twitch hit that
follow button we are just
shy of 50 000 followers on twitch
and remember to grab your memberships at
jointpakman.com we did get 27 people if
you can
look at that look at that beautiful
number that seven is a beautiful number
nice digit um 27 people signed up
we love to see even more i'll see you
guys very soon
you